I'm going to explain a very different
way of going narrower that ultimately
makes you more money so you're not
changing the nature of your avatar
you're just changing you're adding
qualifications to them with at least X
clients y staff and Z Revenue so I
learned about this from the former head
of packaging and pricing at Vista
private Equity they would do a huge
customer analysis of every customer in
the company that they want to acquire if
you look at the 20 of customers that
brought them the most money and look at
the 80 that didn't and they would say
how do we get more of these 20 and
ignore these other ones and so we look
for the common character traits the
channel around that 20 and say what if
we just made all of our customers that
20 when they did that they were able to
5x a company without even having to
incur significant infrastructure across
Because the actual total number of
customers didn't change dramatically and
by doing that became significantly more
profitable and ultimately created a lot
of value you get narrower and the idea
is how do I increase the quality of my
prospects without necessarily going up
Market